-Former President Donald Trump
made his
first post presidency
public appearance
at the Conservative Political
Action Conference
this weekend,
where he and his fellow
Republicans continued to repeat
their deranged
lies about everything from COVID
to the 2020 election
to Mr. Potato Head.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Now, the grotesque symbolism
of Trump's return
to the political spotlight
nearly a year
after the coronavirus
pandemic upended our lives
could not have been more stark.
Remember, it was almost
exactly a year ago
that Trump as President
was saying stuff like this.
-It's going to
disappear one day.
It's like a miracle
it will disappear.
View this the same as the flu.
We're testing everybody
that we need to test.
And we're finding
very little problem.
We're going to be pretty soon
at only five people
and we could be at just one
or two people
over the next short
period of time.
It's a little like the regular
flu that we have flu shots for.
And we'll essentially have a flu
shot for this,
in a fairly quick manner.
When you have 15 people
and the 15
within a couple of days
is going to be down
to close to zero.
That's a pretty good job
we've done.
-Well, hats off.
A pretty good job, indeed.
15 people going down to zero.
Look, I'm as critical
of the man as anyone,
but give credit
where credit's due.
The coronavirus was surging
throughout the world.
But thanks
to Trump's wishful thinking,
we maxed out at 15 cases
and like a miracle,
it disappeared
and quickly went down to zero.
Now, I should say,
as a disclaimer,
immediately after Trump made
that comment,
I went to a year long coma after
I took my kids to skate park
and tried to look cool
by doing the kickflip
at the end of the half pipe.
First, I landed on my nards,
and blacked out from the pain,
and then I woke up
because I blacked out,
forgot what happened.
So I tried the kickflip again
and did it successfully.
Or at least that's what
I thought,
until I woke up
in the hospital
this morning
with a bandage on my head.
Only now my kids tell me
I embarrassed them
at the skate park
and that Trump was way off
on his prediction.
The Seth Meyers you've been
seeing on TV for the last year
has actually been
Eddie Redmayne,
in what I would consider
the role of a lifetime.
While I was in a coma,
I did have an elaborate dream
where I developed a close
personal relationship
with a sea captain.
But that's neither here
nor there anyway.
I guess I shouldn't be surprised
Trump was wrong,
as he's the last person
I'd ever trust
on the subject of miracles.
The guy is the least
religious man in history.
I'm certain he couldn't
even name one miracle
from the Bible
if you asked him.
Jesus took water, channeled it
through a Shell company
and appreciated it
as real estate for tax purposes
so he could record it as a loss,
boom, tax liability gone.
That's why he could afford
two Corinthians.
And that was a big deal
at the time
because most people only had
the one Corinthian.
But Jesus walked through town
with you and people said,
that's a guy
that's a guy you can get behind.
And of course,
it wasn't just Trump
who denied the reality of COVID,
which led to hundreds of
thousands of preventable deaths,
in fact,
at the exact same Conservative
Political Action Conference
one year ago,
former Vice President Mike Pence
had this to say about
the looming coronavirus threat.
-President Donald Trump has no
higher priority
than the health, safety,
and well-being
of the American people.
And while the risk to the
American public remains low.
As the President said yesterday,
we're ready.
No, you weren't. You were ready
for the coronavirus,
the same way Rick Sanchez
was ready for the stun gun.
-I'm about to receive 50000
volts of electricity.
Do it.
[ Yells ]
-Stop.
-Oh. [ Sighs ]
It hurts.
-Oh, does it?
I couldn't tell it from your
preposterous reaction.
Man, the news used to be a lot
easier to make fun of.
Statue of limitations isn't
closed on that one, Sanchez.
My favorite thing
about that clip is how he reacts
like he just ate a hot pepper
and a Bugs Bunny cartoon.
Ay yi, yi, yi!
Those comments
from Trump and Pence
were almost exactly a year ago.
Pence's comments were even
at last year's CPAC.
Fast forward one year.
And of course, we have witnessed
the unimaginable,
devastating toll
of half a million dead
and an economic crash
unprecedented in our lifetimes
that has left millions without
jobs and health insurance
and caused millions more
to experience poverty
and food insecurity.
And if you watch CPAC
this weekend,
it was clear that the ghouls
who either ignored, dismissed
or actively abetted that misery
and suffering have learned
absolutely nothing.
-First, Fauci said, "You don't
need masks, no masks, no good."
Then all of a sudden
he wanted masks.
Now he wants double masks.
-I don't know if you agree
with me,
but Dr. Fauci is wrong a lot.
Now they're saying everybody
can get immunized.
We can have heard
immunity everywhere
and we're going to wear masks
for the next 300 years.
And by the way,
not just one mask, two, three,
four,
you can't have too many masks,
-I'm guessing Cruz's doctor
told him to wear four masks,
but not for the reason
he thinks.
"Ted, if you're not going to
shave that janky beard,
it's the only option.
Goddammit, Ted, listen to me!"
No one wants to hear your whiny
little right wing stand up act.
You sound like
a 50-year-old accountant
trying comedy to distract
yourself from your divorce.
This crowd is electric,
which is nice for me
because my state
doesn't have electricity.
Hey, you don't like these jokes.
Don't blame me.
My daughters wrote them.
In fact, Cruz really did start
out as smarmy little tirade
with a joke about the firestorm
he caused
when he fled
to a luxury resort in Cancun
is his constituents
were freezing to death
in an unprecedented blackout.
-I got to say,
Orlando is awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's not as nice as Cancun.
-Oh, you are ice cold.
Sorry, I meant to say
your constituents are ice cold
because they didn't have heat
for a week but good zinger.
So we went from Cancun
to Orlando with a brief stop
in his home state
in between.
Cruz, roughly has
the same enthusiasm
for helping his constituents
in Texas as Al Pacino
has for attending
the Golden Globes.
[ As Pacino ] Alright. We're
going to lose tonight.
I will see you in the Zoom room.
[ Normal voice ] Looks like he's
going for an Uber at two a.m.
in the lobby of Dan Tana's.
[ As Pacino ] I guess I had
a little too much gristle.
[ Normal voice ] Also, let's
take a second to go back
and talk about South Dakota
Governor Kristi Noem,
who you just heard there,
brag about her state's
coronavirus response,
despite the fact
that South Dakota
has the country's
eighth highest death rate
from COVID-19 overall.
And since July, South Dakota's
mortality rate has been
the highest in the country.
Noem refused to implement
a statewide mask mandate
and bragged about resisting
lockdowns.
In other public health measures
used to curb
the spread of the virus,
South Dakota was infamously
the site of the motorcycle
rally in Sturgis,
which turned out to be
a massive super spreader event
that could have been linked
to over a quarter million cases
across at least a dozen states
that may have seeded an entire
outbreak in the upper Midwest.
I didn't think anyone
could outdo Trump
in spreading the virus,
but she came close.
She might as well packed
a stadium full of people
with fevers
and loaded a T-shirt cannon
with used tissues.
And yet she got a standing
ovation from the wingnut crowd
for saying Fauci
is wrong a lot.
And by the way,
mock him all you want.
I have a feeling Anthony Fauci
doesn't give [Bleep] about
your stupid little zing.
Dude was played
by Brad Pitt on "SNL"
and he's Zoom-ing with
Kim Kardashian,
Katy Perry,
and Matthew McConaughey.
I'm pretty sure he's doing
alright, alright, alright.
When Fauci goes back to
his old Brooklyn neighborhood,
I bet he struts down the street
like a newly-made man
in a chinchilla coat.
"Oh, it's Fauci." "That's right,
Tony the Fauci is back."
"Looking good, Tone."
"Right back at 'cha, Mickey.
"Hey, Dr. Fauci, why don't you
come over sometime?
I'll make you some gabagoo."
"You've got it darling.
Just wear wear two masks
because the kind of cool
Fauci is, is very contagious."
Oh, look at that, Fauci's back.
AL Pacino!"
You're welcome
to come to my Zoom room.
Then Noem tried to take
another victory lap
in an interview on "CBS Sunday"
when she was confronted
with the actual facts
of the disaster
she oversaw in her state,
she did not have
a very convincing response.
-As of today,
the CDC says your state
has the eighth highest death
rate per capita in the U.S.
That's the rate of deaths
per 100,000 residents.
Don't you think your decisions
as an executive contributed?
-You know, South Dakota's
infection rate peaked earlier
than a lot of other places
in the country,
so we're definitely
on the downward trend
and earlier and peaked earlier
than what you're seeing happen
across the country.
-One of your fellow Republicans,
West Virginia's governor,
Jim Justice,
held up your state as an example
of what not to do
when it comes to his decision
to institute a mask mandate.
He said, "I don't want to be
South Dakota."
Why do you think your state
got hit so hard?
-Our state peaked earlier
than other states,
what I'd like to know, Margaret,
is why are -- are you asking
Cuomo these questions?
-Stop saying your state
peaked early.
It's not a defense.
You let the virus run rampant.
You're talking about a deadly
pandemic like a burnout uncle
reminiscing about
his football glory days.
"Oh, sure. I may get winded
on the walk to the mailbox,
but that's only because
I peaked early
should've see, me in Pop Warner,
had an arm like a cannon."
Also, Governor Noem,
I don't know
if you've been watching
the news lately,
but Cuomo has been getting lots
of deserved tough questions
and calls to resign about,
among other things,
credible allegations
of sexual harassment,
covering up the COVID death toll
in nursing homes
and being a bully who makes
threatening phone calls.
It's so bad for Cuomo right now,
even his nipples won out.
I mean, that has to be
what it is, right,
them trying to escape?
Sure. People liked his briefings
early on, But so what?
That was just
in comparison to Trump.
Now that we have a president
who can also correctly
tell us
what day of the week it is,
it's all just
a lot less impressive.
So that's a sample
of what CPAC was like.
Then there was Trump, of course,
he repeated the same demented
lies about
the 2020 election
that fueled
the January 6th insurrection.
I'm not even going to repeat
those lies here
because they're so obviously
unhinged from reality.
He's never offered
a single shred of proof
and he lost 60 times in court.
But I do want
to talk about this.
-What the Trump administration
has done with vaccines,
as in many respects
perhaps saved large portions
of the world,
not only our country,
but large portions of the world.
One hundred percent
of the increased availability.
That we have now was initiated
by our administration.
And as conservatives and
Republicans never forget,
that we did it.
Never let them
take the credit
because they don't deserve
the credit.
They just followed,
now they're following our plan.
I'm what you want credit
for the vaccines.
You left the vaccine
roll out a mess.
There was no plan in place.
You didn't even buy enough
when you had the chance.
What did you do besides,
say, make a vaccine?
I can't imagine you tinkering
and the lab saying
we should use an MRNA platform
instead of an adenovirus.
I mean, if Trump ever even saw
the word MRNA,
he'd probably think
it was a guy named Mr. Nah.
We're working very hard with
Mr. Na to produce more vaccines.
Mr. Na, bad guy. Mean guy.
A nice to me, though. Loves me.
So the Conservative Political
Action Conference
revealed yet again
that the modern conservative
movement is a personality cult,
fostering a sociopathic
political culture
of paranoia
and conspiracy theories
that's fully unmoored
from reality.
At one point, Donald Trump
Junior even suggested
a more accurate name
would be the Trump
Political Action Conference.
-How's it going, CPAC?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or I heard someone earlier
phrase it
a little bit better,
T-PAC.
It's what it feels like, guys.
T-PAC?
Even they didn't know
what to do with that.
You couldn't think
of anything lamer?
I think T-PAC is the name
of a pink-eye medication
T-PAC sounds like the name
of an off brand Tupac hologram
at a festival that couldn't get
the rights to use his real name.
Welcome to
the Couchella Festival.
Please welcome T-PAC,
singing his classic song,
"California Hugs."
Then at another point
Kimberly Guilfoyle suggested
Trump would accomplish more
as an ex-president
than Biden would accomplish
as the actual president.
-I will confidently say that
President Trump from his desk
at Mar-a-Lago
will accomplish more for America
in the next four years
than Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
could ever dream of.
-Have you ever even seen him
at his desk at Mar a Lago?
He looks like a tourist posing
for a photo
at Letterman's old desk.
Just holding a pen
and what appears to be
an empty notepad,
like a therapist who hasn't been
paying attention
during the session.
And yet, the conference
also proved that Trump
is also as politically weak
as he's ever been among the hard
core Republicans at CPAC.
He only got 55 percent
of the vote in a straw poll
and only 68 percent
want him to run again.
If you can't even get above
55 percent with these wingnuts,
how could you ever get a
majority in a national election?
This is your crowd.
It's like if you open a store
that sells monocles
in artisanal pickles
in Williamsburg,
if you don't make
a killing there,
you're not going to do better
in, like, Staten Island.
But the only truly
unifying thing at CPAC,
the beating heart
of modern conservatism,
where the dumb invented culture,
war grievances is evidenced
by their complaints
about total nonsense
like "The Muppets"
and Mr. Potato Head.
-This month alone,
they've banned "The Muppets."
-You see,
last week they tried to cancel
Kermit the Frog and Mr. Potato
Head? You see that?
-Look out, Mr. Potato Head.
You're next.
-I mean, I guess I would be
concerned about Mr. Potato Head
if I answer to Mr. Blockhead,
I mean, Matt Gaetz's,
head has sharper corners
than military sheets.
Also, that's really
what you think Americans care
about amid a pandemic,
and economic crash?
"The Muppets"
and Mr. Potato Head?
My kids don't even care
about "The Muppets"
and Mr. Potato Head.
They want to watch Fortnite
streams on Twitch.
Even though I have been trying
to get them into the new online
Ocean Master, you get tiles
for every reef you explore
and then you use the tiles
to build islands to mine ore.
And whoever mines the most ore
gets to control
the wurfel,
which is German for dice.
It's fun!
The Conservative
Political Action Conference
revealed once again that the
modern conservative movement
remains totally detached
from reality
and the mainstream
American politics.
People care about the pandemic
and the economic crash.
But at CPAC, they're obsessed
with lies about the election.
Mr. Potato Head
and "The Muppets."
And yet still, Trump couldn't
crack 55 percent
when Trump heard
he only got 55 percent.
He must have been like.
-Oh! [ Yells ]
-Stop!
-Oh!
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button,
stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask. We love you.